hey we're on set talking GQ essentials
would timberland so Chris this is like a
perfect fit for you being the creative
director at timber timber lenses dream
job if you mix the outdoors with design
that's what I do
what's the one item that the guys knew
the timber line he's got a trial but I
think there'll be two items be a boot in
the jacket what's the boot I got
happening I would recommend this
Killington bamboo let me have them right
there what's so cool about this is
awesome nothing it's it's classics with
a modern twist it's lightweight it's
easy to wear it's got a great ride
you know I discuss that classic
Timberland DNA so it's sort of a nice
modern sold silhouette on the bottom and
then it's got classic up top totally in
it on the bottom it has our sensor flex
technology so it really makes it very
comfortable with every step so guys if
you're gonna have one boot this season
this is it right here
The Fault every guy should have some
leather in their wardrobe all right this
jacket is awesome and timberlands known
for leather
what's great about this is you have the
personality of a leather jacket but you
actually have a blend with wax canvas
and so you got a lightweight overall
personality but then the details are you
love about them and this is called the
mountain Davis Davis after a mountain in
New Hampshire it's great I love it it's
got the wax cotton makes your leather
it's a perfect silhouette nice and sharp
you got to talk about a great pair of
boots this is the earth keeper it's a
great essential what's behind the name
this was a real inspiration for the
brand this I'm inspired us to think
about creating sustainable Footwear
where we're thinking about where the
leather comes from where the rubber
comes from but still making a really
amazing looking high quality boot again
it's a real modern classic and its
really iconic Timberland so guys
Timberland has you covered for the
modern essentials like we say GQ look
sharp live smart